new jersey is now using churches to
bring covid vaccines to communities that
doctors have overlooked
and underserved fifteen percent of new
jersey's people are black but just
four percent of the residents who've
been vaccinated are black
congratulations
a big difference in the numbers there
our national correspondent jericho
duncan visited a church this one in
somerset new jersey
where the new vaccination push was
launched tarika this is a good idea
our communities churches in black
communities really big deal
yeah they they go hand in hand there's a
history there gail good morning
you know new jersey officials are
working with large churches to help
distribute
the vaccine the church that we visited
has an estimated membership of about 5
000
people and is known for giving back in
that community
so far the church has vaccinated roughly
3 200 people
since valentine's day weekend
congratulations it was a shot of
confidence for
year old dennis hobson i've been praying
that it will be
sooner rather than later that first shot
is like
coming into a new year the weight has
been lifted off my back
hobson's wife tanya who also received
her shot
admits she was skeptical at first but
church town hall meetings put her at
ease
you just have to have the right
information because it's just so much
false information that's going on that
is
you know causing people to hesitate last
month new jersey partnered with select
churches and underserved communities
to help distribute the vaccine the state
plans to expand the effort beyond first
baptist to churches and community sites
in four other cities hoping to vaccinate
15
000 people by the end of march there's
no governor there's no
elected official who wouldn't have
wanted to know more
earlier governor phil murphy toured the
church site last week
when you look at the faces though right
now the people behind you
why is it so critical as you stand here
well in this case there's a lot of folks
of color
and that's the reason the the principal
reason why we are
in this church the virus didn't create
the inequities but it has laid them bare
so i view my job our job to address that
according to the cdc black people are
roughly two times more likely than white
people
to die from the virus and three times
more likely to be hospitalized pastor
deforest sorry says he's glad the state
chose to partner with his church
but wishes it had happened sooner we
knew the vaccine was coming
and it's just curious to me that we
would work so hard to get vaccine
developed we had
a year to put together the
infrastructure for distributing vaccine
whenever it came when we asked the
governor's office about the delay
they told us there was significant
coordination between federal state and
community partners involved
and getting the program off the ground
you tout that there are over 1.75
million shots that have been distributed
in a state made up of nearly 9 million
people
but that you all still have a long way
to go we just need more supplies the
needle is moving in the right direction
it's going to be gradual as opposed to
overnight but i'm confident they'll get
there we'll get there
where would communities of color be
without churches like yours in this
pandemic
without the black church there would
have been no underground railroad
without the black church
we would not have had social protests at
the level of organization that we did
to break down the jim crow laws and
without the black church we will not get
past this pandemic
churches are where people come to for
help it's hugely important
it's central to the life of black people
both historically and futuristically how
much do you think this will now
alter your life you and your husband
travel a lot you get a week we have to
get the second shot so we're scheduled a
month from today
and once we get that second shot i said
let's hit the road
as for the pastor the pain is personal
for him
as it is with many people he said he
lost his sister-in-law
and his nephew to covet and the pastor
told us he was supposed to retire
in november of 2020 but has decided to
stay on to help his community through
this pandemic
some more good news there in new jersey
yesterday the state opened
new sites in patterson and trenton gail
that is good news tariq and i think that
lady has it right let's hit the road a
lot of people want to hit the road let's
get the shot in the arm thank you jerica
duncan